la question de la conservation de
l'accès aujourd'hui par exemple quand
vous rentrez en france
en rentrant de l'étranger à roissy et
vous utilisez le système paraphes pour
pas faire la queue ou pouvons au moins
faire la queue basse par des bagues
vous avez de la reconnaissance faciale
simplement elle n'est pas enregistrée
c'est à dire que le on ne garde pas la
photo alors pourquoi la salle justifie
totalement fait que sinon on pourrait
voyager que le passeport d'un autre voie
là puisque normalement le douanier
identifie que c'est le même qui éclaire
le passeport etc et sur le podium mais
elle serait il faut quelque chose et
vous voyez vous prenez déjà partie parce
que vous dites là ça se justifie
totalement même avoir un débat tronqué
ou et le seuil de la aux astuces
justifie absolument pas en réalité sur
la question de la reconnaissance sociale
tels que j'ai compris que vous la poser
c'est la question de pouvoir identifier
dans une foule quelqu'un et
ultérieurement reconstruire aux époux
c'est la question que se posent les
chinois se servent de la reconnaissance
faciale pour empêcher les hongkongais de
manifester on se dit que demain on
pourrait faire exactement la même chose
le gouvernement français quel qu'il soit
à l'otan intérêt que le gouvernement
chinois est ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
manifester mais c'est désormais bon
moyen de dissuader les gens de
manifester a parlé lbd carrosserie mais
si ça dérange élément spécial mais 6 a
touché des éléments perturbateurs sur
les manifs on parle du mouvement black
book évidemment ils sauront ils sont
masqués
mais si ça peut permettre de suivre
effectivement un gars qui a commis un
délit grave
moi personnellement ça ne me dérange pas
et moi comme un film ça ne me dérange
pas les mêmes gouvernements d'autres
direct si ça dissuade les gens dans leur
totalité de manifester ça ne me dérange
pas je pense pas non sans que je sois
pas les gens de manifestants les
manifestations contre la loi de travail
on avait assigné à résidence des
militants écolos demain on les
identifiera par reconnaissance faciale
éventuellement où les poursuivre en
justice
ils montrent leur nez dans mes cc je
vous rejoins tout à fait là dessus il ya
eu un côté inéluctable de cette
technologie qui font que c'est
absolument unique table on n'y échappera
pas de là l'utilisation la plus évidente
c'est le tout ce qui couvre feu qui
aujourd'hui quelque chose de
relativement théorique et pas forcément
évident à mettre en oeuvre pour les
forces de police mais qui demain sera
d'une simplicité absolue
nora l'identité tout le monde des
policiers de tout le monde il suffira
d'y identifier quelqu'un en dehors de
son lieu d'assignation pour lui envoyer
une amende ou le gign si vraiment c'est
que c'est un très très très dangereux
mais on aura cette possibilité de
réaliser vraiment un des murs
sans la moindre gramme de béton et ça ça
va arriver très très vite
[Musique]